why is aristotle talking about
friendship to begin with
well think about the way that we get
into relationships
and the way that we carry out what we do
in relationships
you can rely on chance or maybe somebody
else
structuring things to do things like you
remember or you had some sort of
orientation week here right
every school does um what do they do
during orientation
besides tell you here's the dorm here's
where the cafeteria is
yeah what do you spend most your time
doing
okay housing you know they go over a
bunch of rules i'm sure
and what to do with your ra and be nice
to each other and that sort of thing
classes we're not going to worry about
that so much
clubs they tell you about clubs why why
do they bother with that
because those clubs are hungry for
members yeah
yeah that's pretty central so you can
meet people
why do you need to meet people
yeah so you know you come here and
you don't know most of the people here
you may know a few people from high
school i suppose
or the person who led you around when
you did your tour
but all of you have formed a lot of new
relationships haven't you over the last
three years you're going to continue to
form a lot of new relationships
some of the people that you've met here
you're not going to stay
that close to them just be realistic
about it right
just like are you friends with everybody
that you were friends with in high
school
to the same degree probably not some of
them um
how did you get to meet them well you
know sometimes it is random
isn't it you just run into somebody i
mean i actually
made some friendships being on the bus
or the train or
uh running into somebody in a conference
that's pretty random
what about reason i mean we're rational
creatures
if you actually join the club because
you say i want to
make some friends you're not doing
something purely random you're doing
something intentional you're thinking it
out right
you say to yourself geez i'm kind of
lonely here i ought to get to
know some people how do i get to do that
you're engaged in problem solving right
i think all of you have done that for
some of you
it's probably been a bit easier because
you're already thrown into something
those of you are athletes
did you come in knowing you were going
to play lacrosse for example
or so from the beginning you had to show
up to practices and
things like that and then you get to
know the guys that you're with right
or you know any other sport presumably
you get to know people in it right i
suppose if you're
a total loner you just wanted to
concentrate on your sport
that might work for a few sports like
track and field
any other ones you can think of that
aren't they're totally not team sports
you guys don't have fencing but fencing
would be like that
um but would that work for for baseball
or softball
i'm not gonna be a team player i suppose
if you're like
some hitting star and all you did was
hit then you could get away with that
but
even so that's not gonna that's not
gonna be that effective
so you think things out you reason them
up in moral life too you know a lot of
what our moral life consists in in our
life
concerns right and wrong good and bad
actions that we make
a lot of it is fairly random but we
bring reason to bear
some relationships you never had a
choice about to begin with
did anybody choose for your mom
you know say to your mom or your dad
i wish you know i was somebody else's
kid
in a fit of anger
none of you did i'm sure some of you did
at one point or another
um most kids go through that i hate you
so once those parents are so much nicer
you know you know they
you don't get to choose all your
relationships do you many of them are
sort of given to you by virtue of who
you are
brothers and sisters how many of you
have siblings
wow almost all of you um in any in any
real
sense did you get to choose your
brothers or sisters
do you sometimes wish that you could
have chosen from a
maybe a pool of options um
oh yeah that's fairly random now notice
though
how do you interact with them again it
could just be at random
sort of catch as one can or you might
actually think about it
as you get um your relationships are
going to change they probably already
have quite a bit while you've been in
college
haven't they and sometimes you have to
think about do i want to stay friends
with this person
how how can i bridge the gap that's
developing between
myself and this other person
well that's that's reason and that's not
just reasoning about a friendship that's
also reasoning about moral life about
what's good and bad about what's going
to make you
happy or miserable about
what the goods in life are how do you
weigh them against each other
and aristotle deals with questions like
this in these two books
questions that on the one hand seem very
personal
and on the other hand seem very
universal
it's interesting to see that some of the
same things that we struggle with
when it comes to relationships were an
issue
back then and they'll probably always be
an issue for human beings as long as we
exist as long as we're the kind of
creatures that we are so like you know
think about this can bad
people become good friends
that's a real issue but we'll explore
that
a bit his answer is no and
we'll see why in a few minutes
think about this should we treat former
friends the same as strangers
or do you have some sort of obligation
to them
based on your your past association
maybe you treat them worse
than strangers you know if the
friendship broke up over some
really big reason yeah
well that would be the stuff that we'd
explore right
um but this is this is posing the the
basic question if they just drift apart
maybe you do treat them like a stranger
they become a stranger
if you quit being friends because they
seduced your
boyfriend or girlfriend or husband or
wife or something like that
maybe then you don't treat them like a
stranger you treat them worse than a
stranger
if um if there's a former boyfriend or
girlfriend
and you broke up and there wasn't
anything acrimonious maybe there's some
sort of
connection there that that should be
honored
these are things to explore in the
concrete
we're looking at the general questions
right now that he talks about
should friendships be broken off and
friends change oftentimes we feel as if
once we're friends with somebody we have
to be friends for life
um you know they have that abbreviation
bff right what does that mean
best friends forever how many of you
have used that
and are no longer in contact with the
person who was your bff
at one time so
it you know just saying that it's
forever doesn't make it forever does it
why why did the friendship dissolve or
fall by the wayside again lots of
concrete reasons
we can explore that later but it
probably had to do with people changing
you know when you went off to college
and you started
to go through some changes
psychologically
and in terms of your knowledge
did you lose any friendships
because things changed right you were no
longer interested
to the same degree and some of the
things that some of your friends were
interested in
there's a lot of cases like that
what do you owe to different friends or
different people that you're related to
do you owe for instance the same sort of
obligations to your friends as you do to
your family
all of you just about all of you i think
raised your hands and said brothers and
sisters
brothers or sisters maybe just one
do you owe business associates
the same thing as you owe towards your
brother or sister
what about your really close friends do
you owe them the same things you
owe it to your family what do you think
how do you feel about it yeah
i think family always comes first so for
me
as much as i give stuff to my friends my
family would always get more
i think there's a lot of people who do
feel that way
what if it was between you and later on
those of you who get married your spouse
if you're forced to choose between
your spouse and your brother or sister
on something
there's some sort of irreconcilable
difference would you say
family first or would you say
i made a commitment to this person
there's a stronger bond
there that's a tough one isn't it
well sometimes you can sometimes
actually the act of staying out will
alienate both
people because
relationships have to do with moral life
when people when you have really serious
problems
and serious divides between people it's
not just over
who turn you know what tv show you're
going to watch or do you like the jets
or the giants or things like that
it's over real serious moral issues is
it right to act this way is it wrong to
act this way
what you know how should one react is
this a screwed up life is this a good
life yeah
well i'm gonna say if you weren't
married or whatever
uh the whole life the family versus like
this
significant other would probably for a
lot of people be a deal breaker
it yeah i think you're right you mean if
the significant other
by the way that they act or the way they
treat other people can't get along with
family yeah
yeah that's why you bring people home to
meet mom and dad
there's an old saying too when you marry
somebody you don't just marry them and
marry their family so you can also look
at that their family
in most cases again there are exceptions
to this and you can look at their family
and you can say
uh do i want to be connected with these
these kind of people over here
maybe their family is a lot like your
family and you say yeah
these are good people i i like this this
this kind of group my family is huge
um we actually tend to assimilate other
people
sort of like the board but you know
brainwash them
my family is when we have our family
reunions which we have
every year it lasts for three days and
in a small one
only about 100 people show up but a big
one it's about 200 people
and i am as close with my first cousins
as i would because most people are
brothers and sisters and i was close to
my third cousins
as most people are their first cousins
it's a very big welcoming family people
marry into it and then they sort of
become part of the giant enclave
a lot of people like that but some
people look at that
and it really turns them off
you know some people don't want that
sort of
closeness it's kind of nice to have a
big network like that i feel
i i'm willing to bet that here at marist
quite a few of you are from
big families like that as well but
that's not the case
in general is it i would say in the
united states
many people don't know their first
cousins
and most people don't really know their
third cousins
very well
and you know so family might mean
different things too right
and who who you're marrying and what
their family looks like
matters so yeah those could be deal
breakers
um why else does aristotle talk about
this
all this friendship stuff there's a few
other important reasons
one is when he was discussing the
virtues all the way back in book two
you remember he said that friendship or
at least
friendliness is a virtue
we're going to look at what's the
difference between friendship
philia and friendliness which is
a part of it you might say friendship is
also important because
i think all of you sort of get this
instinctively in order to live the good
life
you know to flourish to have happiness
to do well
don't you need friends why do you need
friends
or is that a nonsensical question
because it almost answers itself
what do you think why do you need
friends
or why would your life be lacking if you
didn't have friends
have you have you have any of you been
in situations where you didn't have any
friends
for for a while are he's not there in
the place that you were
oh you're saying that you've been in
that situation yeah
um when you first came here to marist
did all of you
have a circle of friends with him did
you feel kind of lonely
did you feel homesick first couple weeks
here
maybe even later on you know after you
went back home for
thanksgiving and then you came back you
know that was pretty nice being at home
i wish i could stay there and maybe
do online classes something like that um
well you you want to have friends don't
you that's part of the good life
um is it is it just because otherwise
you'd be lonely
or is there anything more to it than
living a good life
think about it this way you know
romantic relationships are also part of
what he's calling
friendship bless you why do you want
romantic relationships
we have a sexual desire right but is
that all there is to it
all of you when you when you're dating
just interested in sex
sizing the person up they'll be a good
partner they're attractive
that there's no deal breakers
when it comes to that sort of thing
going on on say the first date
nothing they'd say if they're good
looking and you know they're available
that you know
you might say i think i have a gaps on
this one
i think there's some things right there
um
you know you you want to have somebody
who you
be a good companion don't you
what do you want to do with your friends
what do you guys like to do with your
friends
yeah um i know because when i first came
here
i joined the band pretty much right away
so like i made most of my friends
through the band yeah that makes sense
yeah
um i know that like when we get together
we just really like to hang out and like
have a good time
and more often than not we're doing
something that we needed and we're all
together
so for a lot of my friends i still see
like music
with them so that like we were doing
something
and like we all just really enjoy
spending time with one another we could
just like be doing something principles
like watching tv but we still have
yeah notice there's a lot of activities
you can't do by yourself
i mean let's say we take music you can
play
a song by yourself can you jam by
yourself
by definition no because jamming means
playing
spontaneously with somebody else
um you know you can like do if you play
the right kind of instrument like a
guitar or a banjo or something like that
you can play and sing where you're
supposed to whistle
or hum or whatever you can like do two
things at the same time
i suppose if you're really coordinated a
foot pedal for a drum or
something but that's not the same thing
as actually playing with other people is
it
um can you play sports with other people
or without other people
can you engage in most plays you can
practice
right you know for baseball you can
throw a ball against the
the wall and have it bounce back to you
i suppose you could go in the batting
cage and you know hit hit balls that are
sent to you but isn't it a lot more fun
to actually have another human being
to interact with talking you can talk to
yourself a lot if you want to but that's
not quite as much fun i think is talking
to somebody else
it's about you know assuming they're a
good person to talk with
there's all sorts of things right there
even watching tv is
is i suppose unless you're the kind of
person who really
wants to concentrate on the show and you
don't want to be distracted by
somebody else you know moving around or
talking next to you
for most people they they enjoy watching
tv with other people don't they
my mom was bad with that though you know
she would she would always be asking
questions would be watching the show and
she'd be like now who is that guy
and you'd be like i don't know he just
came on let's let's watch and find out
and drive me and my sister nuts
but most of the time you know you're
you're i think she like to interact
more than we did i think she thought she
was like
livening it up so friendship you know in
order to have the good life you have to
actually be able to share it with other
people
what else is important to share with
your friends
you think of two very different kinds of
things
i mean isn't it nice to be able to
buy things for other people or have
people buy things for you
that's that's a part of friendship you
know isn't it nice to have somebody take
you to dinner
or invite you over to eat um
don't you like to do that with other
people too
in order to practice those those virtues
of like generosity you have to have
friends
otherwise you have to go find somebody
on the street to do it with you know
that's not as much fun what about when
you go through
highs and lows in your life you know
who do you want to have when you have to
go to a funeral
you want to go by yourself probably not
you want a premise don't you
what about when something great happens
isn't it nice to be able to share it
with somebody else
you know you win an award
it feels a little empty if you win the
award and then you go home to
an empty apartment an empty house an
empty dorm room and there's nobody to
talk with about it
you want to be able to share it with
other people so that's another part of
the good life there's also aristotle
says there's a security aspect of
friendship and this is probably
at least with friend friends that's
probably not a big
issue for you yet that'll become a much
bigger issue for you
later on it may have been an issue for
you with family
when your life gets screwed up and
there's a variety of ways in which it
can get screwed up
that's when you really need friends
isn't it when
people are say unjustly criticizing you
or your business is suffering or
you go through a bad breakup or you go
through a divorce
you lose your job
you have you know some other kind of
stuff that's when you can tell who your
real friends are isn't it
because what do they do
they help you
yeah and it might be just emotional it
might actually be financial and
aristotle thinks that that's okay
that that's an important part of our
lives your social networks
are also your support system um that's
an important part of our
our existence aristotle things and if
you don't have that
he talks about the the person who
doesn't exist in society with other
people
being sort of like one piece by itself
in checkers
you know the whole board is laid out the
other person's got all their pieces out
you've got one piece
you're not going to last very long are
you or think about chess if you like
that sort of thing or i think about
sports you know
you're going to play football there's a
whole team out there
one guy with the football how long is
that going to last
well you need friends for the same sort
of reason so friends are very important
for the good life
let's look at what aristotle says
friendship
is and so he distinguishes between
friendship as a habitual state which is
what he's talking about here
and some of the components of friendship
so if we're going to talk about
friendship
in sort of the full sense
or it's a habitual state what else are
habitual states for
arizona the virtues right
or the vices being of a certain kind of
uh character um friendship is
who we're friends with the way in which
we're friends is part of our
our character it's part of our
personality who we are
for better for worse friendship in the
full sense
what does it involve it involves it says
wishing well
for the other person
wanting good things for them wanting
them to
flourish wanting them to do well wanting
things to
go well for them and why
is it for the sake of something else
no it's for
their own sake so if i'm really friends
with somebody
i want them to do well even if i'm not
going to be on the scene
i want their piano recital to go well
even if i'm not there to hear it i want
their marriage to be a
you know a deep abiding relationship in
which both partners are fulfilled
whether i know the person they're
involved with or not
and whether i'm going to benefit from it
or not
true friendship is in a certain way it's
interested in the other person but it's
also you might say disinterested
it's not just seeing the other person as
something that
i'm going to get something out i of i'm
not
getting something out of them doing well
that's not the reason why i wish them
well i wish them all because i like them
because i actually feel something for
them
he talks about the lighting
you wouldn't really say that people are
friends if they can't stand each other
would you
i mean i mean some people hang out with
each other and say yeah we're friends
but
you know you watch them after a while
they're like they're not really friends
they hate each other look at the stuff
they say about each other you know
when the other one's out of the room we
wouldn't call that friendship in the
full sense would we
say friends have to actually like each
other they actually
uh here's another thing feel
sort of affection
for each other it's weird i know a
relationship that's like that
where like when we're around them they
just like
i i said it to my friend the other day
when they had left the room i was like
i don't understand their relationship
like they're
they're always like not kind of
disrespectful to each other
yeah in the end you kind of know that
like they like they love each other you
know
there's some people who antagonize each
other i mean some people
really like to fight yeah you see
couples like that sometimes i think
they're just like like
the personalities well they're getting
something out of it
because you know if they both like to
fight
uh the best person for you to pick to
hang out with them is somebody else who
likes to fight
because you can be guaranteed of getting
what you want you just gotta find some
you know something to you're looking at
me and funny what's wrong with you and
then you get the whole thing started
if you were of that sort of person it
wouldn't be any good to find somebody
who's nice and who doesn't like to fight
who like you know oh no
okay i i didn't mean to look at you that
way you actually want to end them
they couldn't be good friends but they i
mean aristotle would be willing to say
they have a certain kind of friendship
well they're dating
yes that's the relationship i meant like
yeah i've seen
i've seen couples like that sometimes
they start out by
like they meet let's say in a bar or
a party or something and one says
something mean to the other one
and then the other one says something
mean back and they kind of like that
chemistry or antagonism gets them
charged up
and then they just keep on doing it
now on the other hand i've seen some
couples where they genuinely do seem to
hate each other
you know and they stay with each other
maybe because they got married and feel
like they
have to stay that doesn't strike me as a
very happy relationship
that's not going to make you fulfill in
my aristotelian sense
what else is important friends also
benefit
each other
and another thing that you can say about
friends and aristotle things is there
has to be some sort of proximity they
have to
spend time
with each other and aristotle's got this
great problem
friends don't call somebody a friend
unless you've eaten a barrel of salt
with them
not like a big you know barrel but you
know a small
barrel why would you have to eat a
barrel and salt with something
what does that actually mean what do you
put salt on
yeah and so how many
meals do you think you'd have to have
with the person before you could exhaust
you know let's just say instead of a
barrel let's say one of those big
containers of kosher salt
you know you can buy at the supermarket
how long do you think that would last
you
having meals down there well a year
maybe
two years depends on how much salt you
put on things
or if you're eating food at mcdonald's
you just
you hit the barrel within a month well
you know
if you're putting salt on your dollars
no no that's already in there
yeah this is a lot of it but i'm just
messing around with the problem
yeah you don't have to have it in the
inside of the barrel
but the idea is you actually in order to
become good friends with somebody you
actually have to pass
quite a bit of time with them don't call
somebody
friends immediately that's a mistake
people fall into
it's how they get hurt that's how they
get taken advantage of
kids do this a lot you know kids on the
playground
you know they come back after you let
them run around with all the other kids
screaming and yelling and doing whatever
they're going to do
they come back and they say i made a new
friend what's their name
i don't know where they live
i don't know
where their parents somewhere over there
they usually know it's a boy or a girl
you know they can point them out
maybe they know how old they are that's
not really being friends is it
in any real sense um
you can have relationships that don't
meet all of these criteria and those
could be
friendships in a derivative sense and a
lot of the things that aristotle is
going to
call friendship a lot of relationships
are actually in a sort of derivative um
there's another thing that he says
that's i think particularly important
um
he says that that friendship differs
from the emotions of love or enjoyment
or wishing well
those are all things we feel you know
the wishing well to another person
that's a component of friendship
feeling love or affection for the other
person that's a component of friendship
but it's different in that it involves
choice remember we've talked about this
the sense of
choice moral choices being formative of
who you are
of your character so
a true friendship friendship in the
important sense
is something that you've actually chosen
you've
taken on you've made part of
who you are seems a little strange to
say doesn't it
because if the friend goes away
are they still part of who you are in a
sense
but we leave traces on each other
we we don't exist in a vacuum
as a matter of fact we aren't fully who
we are we aren't fully ourselves
apart from other people that we're
connected to
even when people have died they're still
in a certain sense
part of our life they've left their
imprints on this
you know my father has been dead since i
was 11.
but i still think about him and
i have many of his mannerisms and i
remember the things we did
and i think i probably model myself
after him a bit in how i
behave and how i act towards my kids at
least
so in a certain sense he's not
completely gone
that's because we as human beings part
of what our being is is to be
with others those relationships are
really central to who we are
so choosing well in relationships is
really important for moral life
choosing the wrong kind of friends can
screw you up
choosing the right kind of friends can
really
be a benefit to you can't it
um what are what are some things that we
have choices about
with respect to friends who to be
friends with right
what else what else would you say what
choices have you faced when it comes to
your friendships that you've had oh well
so far
since i was younger and like she would
always be like you have to find out the
hard way like
then you have to find out the hard way
and like in high school about finding
out the hard way
and realizing like those people aren't
people i wouldn't surround myself with
yeah when people put you in a difficult
situation where you have to choose
between
some good like their friendship or
popularity or you know
whatever getting to do the things you
like with them and
doing the right thing um
it's hard to call them friends in any
real sense they're
taking advantage of that right and
you're right experience really matters
a lot of these are things you can give
people advice about but they have to
oftentimes we have to go through it
ourselves um
what else what are some other important
things we make choices about
so when i guess when to tell if
somebody's a real
a real friend somebody else had their
hand up too yeah
um well last year i had i lived with
people i was really good friends with
freshman year and then when like you
live with people you start to see things
you didn't before
and i just found out that i have like a
lot of emotional and like mental
background i feel like witnessed some
pretty disturbing things it was like one
of those things like
i was almost like babysitting them to
make sure they didn't do anything so it
was like
is the effort and responsibility that
i'm taking out of this friendship worth
it like
okay yeah that's that's something that
you actually have to make a
determination about
um
you know if you were to for instance say
oh i you know because i've got some sort
of bond with these people i have to do
anything whatsoever i have to sacrifice
myself completely to make sure that
they're okay
that would actually be kind of
pathological aristotle would say that's
not that's not a good thing there are
certain limits that we would want to be
able to to draw on the other hand if you
said
as soon as somebody you know needs help
screw them they're no longer my friend
that wouldn't be very good either
but that would be that would be
determinative of who you are
the way in which you make or break
friendships
what about working through issues
have any of you had to yeah sometimes
that's the hardest part is
working through issues and then once you
get to realizing that there isn't
really the enjoying the other person is
no longer there
sometimes that's the case yeah i mean
if if there's some conflict that arises
or you're going through a difficult
period or something like that
you try to work through things and then
you may clarify
to yourself and the other person hey we
won't have much in common anymore
let's go our separate ways another
possibility
sometimes is that you you
get to know each other better and you
say oh wow i didn't realize we actually
had
so much income and now i care about you
even more
a lot of times this happens when
somebody screws up and then has to
apologize
and try to make it right you know um
sometimes people don't apologize right
yeah
sometimes it's just like the other
person's personality
that yeah i have a perfect example
my my roommate yeah um i live in like a
big enough house
i i asked her if she wanted to move in
with us because
like my rent's pretty affordable and her
fiance like cheated on her
and yeah it was really bad and i was
like well you can move in with us and
she's like
so she moved in and and she moved in
like six months ago and i
we don't even talk anymore because i
realize she's just like really
manipulative
and like uses everybody yeah around her
it's a good thing you have a big house
then then you should
it sounded kind of rough what i said i
said maybe that was the cause of her
fiance
yeah i would never say that no don't say
that yeah
there's a comedian who i forget who it
is and he's talking about relationships
and he says you know if you've had like
20 relationships and they've all gone
sour um and you know
something was wrong with this person
something was wrong with this person
something was wrong
this person there's probably something
wrong with you you know
and there may be something to do
aristotle thinks there are some people
who you can't actually
be friends with if they don't have a
good enough character
if they're not if they're manipulative
for example it's gonna be very one-sided
it's gonna be very difficult
to actually have any sort of deep
friendship with them because
manipulative people by their
by virtue of being manipulative are
always going to be
testing those boundaries yeah
at the moment i have a roommate that i
don't even know how to explain
i talked to her as if she's a second
grader because she doesn't
understand like she doesn't understand
living with other people
you know you can't put the lights on i'm
sleeping or you can't get out from the
net
because you're mad that i'm sleeping
because she doesn't understand that i'm
actually mad and it's just
awful so you actually feel bad about
getting mad
it's like i feel bad that it's so
frustrating because she doesn't
understand yeah but if she's doing
something wrong she'll be like oh well
or you know i guess i'm not quite good
at being quiet or i guess i'm just not
good at living with people
wow that would be some people aren't
good at living without that
yeah that would be very true
i don't i don't think myself i don't
think i could i could stand
some other things that we make choices
about um
to continue a friendship you know
that you've had when you move away this
is something that all of you
had to make choices about um you know
when you when you're in high school you
have a lot of people who you're friends
with you say yeah we're going to stay
friends
in college and all that are you actually
still friends with all of them
at this point
a portion yeah and some of it some of it
has to do with
the not spending time together um now
there are some things that help out with
that in your generation
back in my generation we had to like
write letters to each other that
when i was your agent would you do it
you know
now nowadays you can use facebook or
text each other it's easier to stay in
contact that
that distance is easier to bridge um
but some of these other things you know
benefiting each other
friends aristotle says they actually do
benefit each other
so if the benefit goes away the
friendship may go away
we'll look at that a little bit more
later on
what are you actually looking for in a
friend
what do you want yeah loyalty okay so
a character trick
i think that's pretty important um
the rest of you agree uh what else what
else do you want to go through my friend
yeah um
okay yeah
i think loyalty it has to do in part
maybe with standing up for you
with other people or not referring other
people to you
and trustworthiness maybe has to do with
your individual
relations could think some things could
involve both like to tell somebody a
secret
you know you're going to trust them with
a secret you hope they're trustworthy
and they're loyal in the sense that they
don't tell like you know
maybe the secret is you don't like so
and so you don't want your friend to go
over and tell so and so that do you
um what else what are some other things
yeah uh since you
i think that's probably important
and aristotle thinks so too we'll see
why in just a minute
that they're sort of um affectionate
they're they're nice at least here right
yeah like similar values like what
they're valued
very important
similar values
how about one more yeah
they listen okay um
in what sense um
like you tell them what to do they
listen to you like i'm really
understanding or like
okay so they listen they
let's say they try to understand
they make an effort
they care about who you are you're not
just a number you're not just a
stand-in for them you know until the
next person
um something goes wrong they actually
want to know what's
what's going wrong um
we'll come back to what do you have to
offer friends because i'm willing to bet
that
for a lot of you these are some of the
things you actually have to offer
friends what are deal breakers
what are things where you would say all
right that's it we're done
i'm not friends with you anymore yeah
starting to follow
okay bullying um
that does happen in some friendships
right one one friend dominates the other
what are some other things that are like
bullying um belittling
sometimes friends you know
tear each other down any other things
like bullying or belittling that would
fit in there
um maybe we'll think of some more as
it goes on what else are deal breakers
yeah does that look like
because i mean being a bully is kind of
deal with it what are other ways people
are manipulating
um
partial information you know like some
people like to like conflict
so they'll steer people against each
other
um but tell this person over here
that person doesn't like you when they
go over to this person they don't like
you either they said this and this about
you
and then the two people come together
and like what's your problem with me
and then you know sometimes if you don't
get angry enough
you can actually like figure out that
third person
was manipulating him sometimes you get
angry and then you can get into a big
fight
i actually had a kid who
almost got me to fight with this other
kid in high school
after school and this other kid was like
a bar fighter
he would just stun people and i was kind
of you know
kind of scared to actually have to go
fight this kid but you don't you know
you don't back down
right and um it was that same sort of
situation he manipulated us both into
thinking that the other person
for no reason whatsoever wanted to fight
luckily we compared stories who knows
what
happened you know what else are deal
breakers
yeah why why is lion so
so um so bad what happens when
people lie in a friendship
and some people just lie to lie right
they enjoy it
what are some of the damaging
repercussions
yeah that trustworthiness is destroyed
isn't it when people lie
what if you um become friends with
somebody and
later on you find out that what you
thought you actually had in common
they lied about because they they liked
you they wanted to hang out with you
but they really really don't have that
in common with you how do you how does
that make you feel
they one day came up to you and said
because it's showing that they're
willing to
make some sort of sacrifice
what did you find out that they don't
really like this kind of music
they don't really like these restaurants
they're not really into reading this
kind of book
as a matter of fact you know you're into
reading they're not into reading at all
um you know the lies get bigger and
bigger
then we start to feel as if you're not
the person i thought you were
i don't want to be friends with you i
don't want to be friends with that other
person i thought you were
yeah that would be kind of creepy
yeah we make movies like that don't we
um
and people do this sort of thing you
know
i i had a friend um who i think i may
have mentioned before
and we listened to heavy metal when i
was in high school and i still like
having that a lot today
and so we'd get in his truck and we'd
drive around he had all these these
cassettes back then
and we listened to it and then he had um
one cassette
of whitney houston and what do you have
whitney houston for
do you like whitney houston well
did somebody else leave it in your your
truck
no that's what i play when chips are in
the trunk i tell them i really like it
because they like it you know this is
fairly transparent
all a woman would have to do is like
look down and see
one one way to use the tape and all the
rest is you know ac dc iron made and
all this other very heavy stuff and say
well this guy is
you know not really
not really into this why does he only
have one cassette
um but you know that's sort of like that
that line what else what are other deal
breakers right yeah
like when a person is like
that's good because that tells you
something about
their character right you mean other
people
and particularly to your own
friends or also maybe family
somebody puts down your family you
probably don't like that i'm willing to
bet right
um any other
killers yeah um
one-sided relationship okay um
you can see it and one-sided and in what
way what does
that like um like when people come
become like so conceited or
into themselves where you know it's
supposed to be like
a two-way like relationship you're
supposed to be like asking about that
other person
yeah you should be asking about you but
when it becomes all about them
because they're self-centered
they're not able to be a good friend
because they want to tell you about
their day they're not interested in your
day you have a story about this
that's so great because they have a
story and it's even bigger than your
story
um you feel
bad well you know they feel even worse
um but it's always about that yeah i
think that that's that's a good one
it's hard to stay friends with somebody
like that for a long time
so let's let's think about before we
actually look at aristotle's three
different
types of friendship let's look at the
whole spectrum of different
relationships that we have
and again rather than just using the
word friendship
let's use the broader term
relationship obviously friends
our one subclass
who else are you connected with who else
do you interact with
family right that's really
and you know what friends in the sense
that we use the term may
come inside his family or it may not
there are some people
for instance my mother's generation of
our family
they all lived on the same block in
chicago they're all a bunch of
poor french canadian kids most of them
actually speaking french before speaking
english
speaking french in the home
their friends for the most part were
their family
and then a few other people from from
the neighborhood who
um wound up being connected with them
like you know there were a lot of
menominee indians in the neighborhood as
well
the menominee and french who wanted
history together
then they were you know when they went
to school they were the irish kids
you know because they all went to
catholic school
your family could be your friends or you
might not actually like your family
but you're still related to them right
you also have that expression
you can how's it go
you can pick your friends and you can't
pick your family
don't say that by the way like the
family reunion because that'll probably
you know take somebody off um but these
are these are sometimes different
categories
sometimes you can have somebody in your
family who could stand
for a while and then you become friends
like you know your brothers or sisters
you may not like them when they're kids
you may not like them when you're
20 30 and you get to like them when
you're 40
or maybe you like them when you're kids
and then you don't like who they become
they're still your family though aren't
they okay so these are big categories
who else
co-workers co-workers yeah
for americans
a lot of our relationships develop
through work
uh because we're you know working
society yeah
maybe like strangers or potential
friends
uh okay let's put that down as uh
um who else who else
do you have yeah for significant others
and family
that's an interesting question i would
actually include them
as a second camera and there's there's
reasons why with paris level
and let's use that um i always tend to
think of it in terms of
boyfriend girlfriend spouse but
significant other
is perhaps
generic enough to cover anything that we
want
it's funny because you know if you look
at certain languages like french has all
these euphemisms for boyfriend or
girlfriend that involve
the notion of friendship uh
you know on me you say that somebody is
uh
you're on me they may actually be your
your
person you're dating um
yeah significant others they they can
become family i guess if you marry them
um but then there's there's still
supposed to be something a bit distinct
to that isn't there
family's off limits for that too right
hopefully
your significant other might might be
part of your circle of friends
this is another thing too many people
find their mates on the job
here in the united states um who else
who else are you connected with yeah
yeah i think that's very important
classmates um and you guys
and professors professors
and you may and you probably won't keep
in touch with most of your your
professors i'm guessing
i know i didn't
you probably have colleagues i suppose
that would be like co-workers
so let's actually colleagues
um people will do the same kind of
job that you do but maybe you're not in
the same location
um they may end up they may actually be
used like your classmates for a lot of
your colleagues
depending on what you're doing anything
else any other
relationships that you could think of
that you had
neighbors say your neighbors favors yeah
nuts you might not actually be friends
with them you're kind of stuck with them
one second
they are not the same thing necessarily
as co-workers or family or friends
classmates i for you guys if you're
living in the dorms they are classmates
in a sense
yeah go ahead um
well let's okay we'll put that into um
what else what about
other involvements that you have
teammates are any of you in any clubs or
organizations
so we call people
fellow club mates we have a term
in english for them members i think is
what is a club member
yeah well let's put members yeah
um organizations that you belong to you
get to know people through that
there are organizations that exist just
to connect people up with each other
networking organizations
right those of you who get into business
probably should join the uh the rotary
club or the chamber of commerce or
things like that
there's other groups too you know people
have common experiences
sometimes like people go through
basic training together not even
together they just
belong to the same military at one time
there's a connection there to two people
who are in different police forces
they both recognize each other as cops
but sometimes there's a little bit of
rivalry though right like state
don't necessarily like sheriffs
but they do recognize each other as
having the same sort of profession
teachers recognize each other as
teachers i think maybe that's
like calling so you think
what are the relationships that other
people have
that maybe you don't have any anything
we've left out we think
your whole sort of network
of ideal and real relations i
he's not our mailman anymore but i used
to have a relationship with our mailman
okay is that just does that just become
a friend
or is that well i think aristotle would
say that that
fits under this big umbrella of
friendship as he's describing it
uh what would we call that i mean yeah
you get to know
let's call these sort of commercial
for a business uh
the person who cuts your hair yeah any
of you go to barbers
or hairstylists or
you get to know them after a while you
go to the same person they ask you you
know they
sort of shoot the breeze what are you
been up to they're not your friend like
you're not inviting them to dinner are
you but you know
you treat them a little bit differently
than you would a complete stranger
so there's some sort of relationship
there if you become a regular at a
restaurant or a bar
you get to know the people there as well
right and they get to know you
that's part of why you might go go back
to the same place because you enjoy that
that connection that you have
for some people that may be the only
contact that they have during the day
what else you know social media has kind
of switched things up a bit
do you have any any connections on
social media
that don't necessarily fit into
these people that maybe you got a friend
request from and you don't actually know
them but you said
okay i don't ever do that
yeah it's kind of funny in college towns
guys have gotten in trouble because some
police departments
would actually put up a picture of a
pretty woman and can't come up with a
fake name for her
and then have her do friend requests
and they would and then once they got
the friend thing they would go and look
at people's pictures
and if they saw underage drinking or
drug use
then they'd go and they'd take the photo
and then they'd go bust the person
and the reason they were able to get
guys with this and not
women is most women are not going even
if the guy is good looking
are not going to accept a friend request
out of the blue
just on the off chance that maybe this
will be interesting
a lot of guys especially college age
guys pretty
pretty woman you know don't know who she
is or where she came from or anything
like that
but sure we'll put her on the list all
right
there are you know social media
connections
and it's interesting because social
media has allowed us to tie
a lot of these things together
just sort of you know as an assignment
how many of you use facebook everybody
in the class uses facebook
how many of you use linkedin
about half of the class
what about twitter
it's almost the same people who use
linkedin and use twitter
which is kind of interesting um what
about
google plus didn't even use google plus
and i got rid of it yeah it's still it's
still kind of in development
what's interesting about that is google
plus forces you to decide
where you want to place people in
certain circles right facebook now lets
you do that
in important ways well google plus is
kind of scary in the privacy aspect
with google so that's that's facebook
well not not
to the same extent you kind of have a
little bit more control
of your information than you do on
google plus everywhere
on facebook
oh yeah which is why i got rid of it
yeah i think
google plus right now
it's more used by people who have
particular interests that connect up
with
other people of those interests it's not
facebook is just more of a
you connect up with all the people that
you're involved like your family
and with 70 families facebook friends
your friends classmates all that sort of
stuff
so facebook twitter linkedin
google plus pinterest how many of you
are on pinterest
only a few okay that one's now the third
largest
uh social networking community it's
primarily
like i i thought it was like very like
primarily
toward females like from the books of it
every time i walk by a computer it's
usually women who are on it
yeah the majority of pinterest users are
are women
the majority of linkedin users are men
um
but they're for instance i have a
pinterest account and i use it
i put like a whole bunch of different
things in there because it's kind of
handy for
accumulating photos and links people
like them
so there's not an awful lot of
interaction that takes place my
girlfriend spends like hours on i think
just looking at everything
really she's addicted to it i think it's
the visual
aspect of it yeah it's fun to look at
images
aerosol realizes this we like to do that
together we like to share images
there's something that appeals to us in
that and yeah you can
easily use a lot of time instead of
scanning around them
i don't like you know i think a lot of
the images tend to be things like uh
clothing or i'd like to buy this and i
find that kind of boring myself
i put things like images of the artistic
representations of the seven deadly
citizens
or famous philosophers or things like
that um
now here's the point though in the
social media they tie
it's a way to tie all these things
together it's a way to sustain
relationships
over time and space that didn't exist
for aristotle didn't even really exist
in an easy way in my generation
i had the experience that you guys
aren't going to have because you had
facebook practically speaking the whole
time that you've been in
high school and college available to you
i reconnected with a whole bunch of
people who i had
seen for years and years and years and
actually haven't seen physically
still most of them for at least 20 years
through
facebook you know i'm probably connected
with a good
80 or 90 people from my graduating class
from high school i've seen maybe three
or four of them since
but i interact with them but
i could be friends with them in some
sense we've actually talked about
important things
a lot of us went through
breakups or divorces or you know major
life changes and we talk about that
stuff
that's part of what forms and sustains
friendships
so social media kind of changes the
picture a bit
for you guys you have the possibility of
remaining connected
and being able to figure out what's
going on with your friends
or your acquaintances or however you
want to
call it for you know
the rest of your life what do the
different social networks do
does linkedin do the same sort of thing
as facebook
what do you use linkedin
it's kind of like an online resume and
like you can
talk about yourself like professionally
more so than socially
yeah it's much more for professional
advancements
than yeah like the majority of my
connections like on linkedin
are of course like current classmates
and some are like prospective employers
or people who are going to like
you know things that they've held at
their offices like for potential
candidates
i think primarily in the future the main
benefit of it is
let's say you're looking to make a job
change and you have all these
connections with your classmates and
you can tell what kind of job they're in
what field they're in it's a very easy
way to find out
hey this is the person who i'd want to
talk to if i have an interest in this
field
yeah that's now this is kind of a good
segue to thinking about these three
different kinds of relationships that
aristotle
talks about
so now aristotle talks about three
different kinds three basic types of
friendship and he says
there are three things in terms of which
we
love or feel affection towards other
people
what are they they're three different
kinds of goods and
there is the useful good utility
this is how it's translated there
um and this this covers a whole range
right there's a lot of people who we are
actually
friendly with we're in some sort of
relationship with them
because we're getting something out of
it and they're getting something out of
it
you know business partners right
sometimes they hate each other
but they'll stay business partners why
because they're making money
not all actors or writers or
i suppose sports people as well like
their agents
but they'll go to their agent's house
for for dinner
their agents probably don't like their
clients very much but they'll
you know spend time together and
we do a lot of social events with people
that we're not particularly fond of
don't
one way or another i mean as you as you
get older and you become more involved
in
the place that you live and
business whatever it is that you're
going into you're going to end up in
more and more relationships
like that
what else would be friendships with
utility well i think that
self-centered person they're they're
just using the other person aren't they
they're not really giving um you almost
sometimes feel like you're a satellite
orbiting them you know they're
they're the real center of the universe
at least their universe
what else what are other ways in which
we just focus on
getting something out of somebody else
yeah you're paying somebody to do
something for you
yeah if you're actually paying if you're
somebody's on your payroll
and then they're showing up to your
christmas party um
and they wouldn't show up otherwise
you're not really good friends
you know and they're probably not even
doing it because they enjoy it they're
doing it because they're they're getting
paid
probably a lot of people have entourages
their hangers on
are people who are friends with them for
the sake of usefulness
and i think you can find a lot of these
deal deal-breaking qualities sometimes
in friendships that are based on utility
aristotle says these don't last them
awful
in a long time then there's friendships
that are based on
pleasure pleasures are good we all enjoy
having a good time don't we aristotle
doesn't think that pleasure is a bad
thing
he doesn't think it's the the all and
end all of them in life
but it's pretty important in a good life
sense of humor i think would fall in
there wouldn't it
do you like being around people who
can't get your jokes
how many of you like telling jokes
not that many of you how many of you
like to laugh
okay all of you good um
do you like hanging out with people who
don't laugh at the same things that you
do
probably not you know that's important
that's that's one of the main sources of
pleasure that we have
um what are other ways in which we get
pleasure from from other people
good conversation all right
some of these qualities like being kind
or affectionate isn't it nice to be with
people who
treat you treat you well
even if maybe they don't know you that
well they treat you nicely
or do you guys like to be treated mean
and if you're masochists
you're really going to kick out of
somebody knocking you down and
bullying you or something like that good
none of you raised your hands
um common interests you know
so long as we have a common interest
with somebody very often that's
pleasurable
if you like playing um basketball with
that
that group of you know people even you
go to the
park and play a pickup game for a little
while you're friendly with each other
you may actually be rivaling each other
too and
what kind of player you are but you know
if you're a real jerk they'll probably
kick you off the court
won't they it's not gonna last very long
but you could show up to other things
and find things where you have common
interests
and you immediately sort of latch on to
other people
that your example about band is a good
example
musicians have something in common with
each other first off they actually like
playing music
that's a big one right there they may
actually have a lot more specific things
in common
how they spend their day liking this
particular composer
or this kind of music you know they've
thought about those sorts of things
what else what are other common
interests that you
that ties you together with your friends
same sports team maybe liking the same
shows
um saying music is often
pretty important what else are important
in your own interesting
think about your friendships that you've
got
what do you have in common with your
friends
yeah uh
that's really important actually
yeah i don't think we call that a common
interest so much as something like
common life situation
one of the biggest complaints that gets
made and again we make
sitcoms and movies about this is that
when
when a friend gets married he or she
quits hanging out with their group of
guys or
or girls that they were hanging out with
before and
you know sometimes it's like you're dead
you know or something like that
and why because they find more
fulfillment in a new stage
and you notice too if you you guys
probably have
been through this when you're involved
with somebody now you're a couple right
and you still do as much stuff with um
other single people or you now start
doing things with
other couples
as it goes on you're going to actually
start doing more and more stuff
the older you get with other people who
are couples
which then is going to pose a problem
when someone break up or get divorced or
things like that
when you start having kids people who
have kids
have some that's not again it's not so
much a common interest
i don't think you call your children
your interests would you
but you have a common connection you
have a common life situation
those who've been through um certain
experiences too right
you're going to marist somebody else
wearing marist gear you run into them
in france you see a marist hat
you're going to want to know did you
actually go to marist oh when did you go
you start talking with them and you may
become friends with them
did you have you know professor
so-and-so oh they were awful yeah
i think they were awful too now you
actually have something in common don't
you
even complaining about things could be
something in common
being a vet because i'm a veteran
i have an immediate easy connection with
with other people who served
what are other things like that i
suppose having been in prison
not not in the sense that i taught in
prison but you know people who actually
have been
in prison have a connection they have a
common experience that they can share
with other ex-cons
so a lot of different life situations
yeah we could fit into that
and some of those may be again matters
of pleasure it's pleasant to be with
people who are like us
some of those may open up opportunities
for usefulness
think about it again with kids if you
make friends
with other people who have
what does that open up for you what
opportunities
when you have kids and you have them for
a long time
one of the things you're going to want
to do is find ways to be
away from your kids every every parent
goes through this and it's normal and
it's you know provided you're not like
abandoning them
and going out to the store or you know
to the bar or something that's okay
what do parents do with each other uh
which is not really about pleasure
but more about usefulness with each
other
play dates what are play dates
those are opportunities to drop your kid
off and take off
and be without them for two four you
know six hours
and have somebody else occupied with
your kid for a while
now that's providing you with pleasure i
suppose because you have to do something
that you like to do maybe even just have
some peace and quiet
for some parents depending on what their
home life is like
but it's more a relationship of
usefulness right if we're all a bunch of
parents and we we get together
all right you're going to watch the kids
uh
this day you're going to watch the kids
this day we'd make like sort of a pool
what about study groups for you guys do
you ever
pool your resources that way other
students
yeah are you like really close friends
with everybody in your study group
close friends might not be the best
people to study with who do you want to
study
the smart kids the ones who actually
know the material that are
you know not necessarily the smart ones
the devoted ones who actually studied
you know who buckled down you may be
those kids you may have people knocking
at your door
hey um you think we can study together
and we've talked about why some of you
don't like group work because you feel
other people sort of
glowing onto you that would be treating
you as somebody useful wouldn't it
um then there's so we have usefulness
we have pleasure pleasure is a higher
form of friendship
oh one other kind of pleasure that we
should talk about romantic relationships
when you have a romantic relationship
when you're you know dating somebody
when you're
meeting somebody somewhere you're giving
somebody
your your phone number texting back and
forth
what does it feel like i'm gonna first
say first couple weeks of a new
romance new attraction what's that like
is that just useful for you
probably not is it pleasurable
yeah it's intensely pleasurable right to
fall in love to be in love
there's people who like love to be in
love or
desire to be alone just to have that
feeling
if it actually starts working out well
between you and this person
do you find them pleasant
i hope so if you find them unpleasant
if they have these sorts of behaviors
that's not a friendship of pleasure
anymore
is it then you probably should quit
dating them
don't marry them definitely if they do
this
stuff um but if they have all these sort
of things
that's pretty important
isn't it and you know it's
it's great if people have similar values
with you when we're talking about
romantic relationships
we mean things like you know do you
actually find yourself attracted to them
are they your type there's lots of
different types right
um do you find their voice intoxicating
or irritating
you know do you find their laugh um
enjoyable or like grating on your ears
like friend dressers laugh um
i don't think she actually laughs
probably
those are important things that all
again has to do with pleasure and those
sorts of things
fall into relationships of pleasure um
let's look at the third kind of so what
else can you be friends with somebody in
terms of
this is i think where we get this
similar values issue
and maybe to a certain extent that's
listening or trying to understand
what goes beyond mere pleasure that
you're getting from a friend
however important that is
yeah in a sense although that could just
be usefulness again like i'll watch your
kids you watch my kids
that way we don't go nuts and that sort
of thing um
if somebody's actually support system is
a good way to talk about it though
because if somebody really is listening
to you
trying to understand who had that one
yeah um
what is it that you're looking for let's
let's dig into that a little bit more
what are you actually looking for from
somebody
who does that
okay would you be would you be okay with
a friend telling you
what you're thinking isn't okay you're
you're screwing up
let's say you are screaming would it
would be good to have a friend who calls
you on yourself
yeah we need other people to help us
figure things out
nobody is so smart aerosol thinks that
they can
work everything out on their own that's
an important role of practice
if you're telling a friend your problems
what sort of reactions wouldn't you like
from them
i suppose yeah that would not be good at
all um
laughing at them maybe this is good
material i'm going to put this into a
script
that wouldn't be good either would what
do you want
what sort of behavior should they show
yeah okay
they should be engaged so they're not
like um
texting somebody else or checking their
email while
you're telling them about you know this
thing that's really bothering you
you want them to care about you right
not just you because you give them
pleasure
not just you because you're useful to
them but you who you
are the individual that you are the
person
you want them to remember things about
you too right so you don't keep telling
them the same thing
time after time uh you actually want
somebody to
i think this this goes for romantic
relationships as well unless you just
want somebody to
sleep with you want somebody to want to
know who you
are to be curious about you
to make you something important
to make you a person who matters to them
a lot of that goes into good listening a
good listener
makes the person feel at least for that
time that they're listening
like they are the center of the world
and whatever issues they've got
or joys they want to share really
matter you know if your response to
somebody when they're telling you about
things is
what's that to me then you're not really
being a
good friend of them are you um if they
say that to you
how does that make you feel you got to
make this relevant to me
that's not being engaged is it um
similar values too that's really
central isn't it can you be friends
can you be deep friends with somebody
who doesn't respect the sort of things
that you respect
who holds opposite views to you
he thinks you know i imagine if we've
talked about this before music is pretty
important to you
you know can you be really close friends
with somebody who thinks
that music is the total waste of time
yeah because in a way that would be
not recognizing something that's that's
important to you
what about somebody who says loyalty is
not really that important
they come right out and say that to you
could you be good friends with them
it's just user be used you know that's a
sign don't trust this person
i think and it would be very difficult
to be friends with them
the exceptions for aerosol would be like
the ones that you're stuck with like
family some some you know bonds that you
have
you don't have much of a choice about
now aristotle says a few other things
about these these different kinds of
friendship
so let's let's go back to thinking about
friendship and utility and we said
business relationships fit into this
cases where you're paying somebody for
something
um i suppose if you had a butler or a
servant or something like that that
would be
that kind of relationship as well
usefulness is
you're getting something you know
you're getting something monetary you're
getting something that you need
it's based on
satisfying needs
i scratch your back you scratch my back
that's that's
you know one of the proverbs that we
have and that sort of thing
when we talk about friends using each
other there might be
somebody who's friends with somebody
else so that they can go to all the good
parties
right the other person wants them around
so that they
feel validated and feel popular neither
one really likes each other
that would be just usefulness wouldn't
it people use each other
let's say you have a sexual relationship
where one person is
actually getting pleasure out of it and
the other person is is getting something
else out
you know maybe they're i mean we could
reduce it to a really basic level
prostitution
one person is doing it for pleasure sake
the other person is doing it just for
money
probably they don't even enjoy it you
know
um or you know what are other reasons
that people do that sort of thing
security you know want a nice nice place
to live
to be popular um
to set them up to take a fall you know
like in film noir movies right
what are other cases like that people
use each other
well when it comes like listening some
friends just
use you to get attention and then when
you start talking they're just like
whatever yeah and maybe you could like
make a deal with them
and say if you don't pay attention to me
i'm going to quit paying attention to
you
and you make it really clear that i have
a need for attention just like you do
you're not really good friends with that
person if you have to spell that out
you know so then above that we have
pleasure
and friendships that are based on
pleasure
are um a bit more
durable right they're a bit more
lasting
the person has some sort of trait
a friend gives pleasure in one way or
another and there's so many different
pleasures that we
we couldn't possibly enumerate all of
them
delighting in the same kind of activity
is like this so you know if you
enjoy cooking together making music
together
some people just like going dancing you
know they'll go out with somebody
because they're a good dancer
or they like to dance and that's that's
it
romantic relationships like we said fit
into this aristotle also says that
friendships between younger people are
typically of this sort as well
you know kids that play together on the
playground are doing so because they
enjoy it right
they're not doing it because they're
setting up you know their future
business life
if they they are they're really strange
kids
they're doing it because they enjoy
hanging out with each other
and when the pleasure goes away what's
going to happen to the friendship
usually
in your experience
people that you don't want to share
common interests with are you still
friends with them
oh god people used to hang out with
enjoy time you may have actually made
some friends here at marriage that
you're no longer friends with even at
marist
you hung out with them freshman year but
you don't anymore aristotle says that's
okay
i mean if it was just based on pleasure
if that's what the point of the
relationship was
then when the pleasure ceases the
relationship should probably cease
unless it's you know some sort of role
relationship like you know
parent to child or sibling to sibling
something along those lines
then there's relationships that are
based on
virtue or character
and aristotle says these are actually
kind of rare
believe it or not he says that um
people who are genuinely good or at
least striving to be so
can be friends with each other in this
way where they actually
know the other person and they value the
other person
for the sake of that person so somebody
who knows you
and cares about you as who you are not
necessarily for everything that's good
about you
they may in fact recognize you know bad
qualities in you too but they still love
you
they still care about you
as a matter of fact they may not even
overlook all the bad qualities you may
drive them nuts sometimes
but they still value you and what's good
for you
they want you to do well they want you
to prosper
they see the good things in you as well
they want to know who you are they want
to continue to know who you are
that's friendship in terms of character
or virtue my hope is that all of you
experience that
at least at least once at this point and
that you'll continue to experience that
through your life uh aristotle thinks
you can only have a few people like this
i'm not quite so sure about that i think
it's possible to have
quite a few relationships like this
but it does take work because to get to
really know somebody on that level not
just on the surface level as you would
with
pleasure utility takes time doesn't it
and how do you know if somebody's really
a good person
you have to go through some experiences
with them don't you
if you want to know if your friend is
actually loyal or trustworthy
you've got to go through some
experiences where that's put to the test
and some of your friends i think in the
past have measured up to that and some
of your friends haven't
is that the case yeah
um now what's interesting
aristotle says this is the most lasting
kind of friendship
because it doesn't go away if the
pleasure goes away or the usefulness
goes away
it's based on who the person really is
that doesn't mean that it doesn't have
plenty or usefulness
otherwise hanging out with them for
pleasure's sake wouldn't we
those who are connected to in terms of
virtue or character who they are
their personality um we
usually do also find them cousins
although they may call us on our
on our stuff you know they may say hey
you're screwing up
knock it off we don't like that do we
that's kind of unpleasant
but if it's actually for our good and
you can recognize it later on
it usually has to happen later on one
second and then you say oh
this person really actually does care
about these other jerks over here
who are saying yeah that's fine do what
you want they don't actually care about
me
this person does yeah can that
and that's where aristotle talks about
what could translate is unequal or mixed
friendships
um those are cases where say one person
is is virtuous
and the other person wants to be with
them because you know virtuous people
are often
quite nice to be around because they are
trustworthy and they you know they are
generous and they don't screw you over
and they
you know there's something about virtue
about good character
when we look at it we admire it we
find it pleasant so it could be that one
person is getting
pleasure out of it uh the person who's
actually virtuous is just getting
pleasure from the other person because
that's the best they can give
and the person who's virtuous says
that's okay i i'm fine with that
that's that's the most they can provide
me or even just you know
um utility you know
they're give a great person who's on the
payroll of somebody else who's not a
particularly good person but that
that person can at least recognize that
this person is great and this virtuous
person is giving better
things in return um so
yeah you can have unequal friendships in
general if you have two people that are
like this or
even better a group of people like this
imagine you have three friends like this
or four or five it's going to be
pleasant to be with them
because you actually have not only some
other things in common
you have the most important thing in
common
wanting to be a good person these common
values that we
were talking about before and
good friends are actually useful to each
other the people who are
virtuous will help each other out in a
pinch won't they
otherwise you wouldn't really call them
virtuous would you you know
if your friend doesn't help you out when
you need it are they are they really
generous
probably not
so those are those are the longest
lasting ones another
thing that you can think about with this
when you experienced the loss
i think all of you have experienced
losses at this point and you're gonna
unfortunately have many more coming up
who do you miss the most um
if it's just a you know sort of almost a
business transaction
do you really miss them
they're easily replaceable aren't they
you can find somebody else to do the
same thing
it was just usefulness what about
pleasant friends
you miss the pleasure do you miss that
i mean i think that
there may be cases where these kind of
blend into each other
maybe if you actually miss the person
it's no longer just about the pleasure
it's also about
who they are that kind of person but
there are some cases where
yeah it was fun to hang out with this
group of guys but um
i'll find another group because this
group's gone
um you can say some some cases you know
things just
are meant not to last you know like
again pick up game of basketball
you're not going to actually like
exchange business cards and say okay
next week this same time we're all
getting together because it's a pickup
game
you don't have any expectation of
actually continuing it
or if you go to go to a bar sports bar
watch the game
you know cheering on whoever it is that
you guys like
you know um you're all going home to
separate places afterwards
i think and you may not ever go back
there yet
but for for a while you've shared that
um when you lose a friend who you
actually got to know
who you found you really liked who
really liked you
but you felt there was a connection
then you really feel like there's a big
loss don't you and are they easy to
replace
why not think of romantic relationships
like this too
romantic relationships could just be
pleasure
or they could involve what we call
intimacy
intimacy is really a matter of
going beyond just the physical aspects
of the person and getting to know who
they are
and coming to love you know we often say
oh those persons you know
got a great personality and use that as
an excuse for you know why
it's okay that they're not physically
attracted great personalities are
actually pretty important isn't it
because physical attractiveness
that goes away and um
put a person in the wrong light suddenly
they're no longer that attractive
put them against a person who's even
more attractive suddenly they pale in
comparison
what about personality though
that's not quite so different isn't it
that should that does stay the same over
time that actually gets better and
better
if you if you fall in love with somebody
and you want to make a go of it a real
relationship
you're probably going to want to develop
this kind of level of relationship with
them
if it's only about physical things about
pleasure
maybe they have a good personality in
the sense of having a good sense of
humor or something like that
as soon as that stuff goes the
relationship is no longer gonna
fulfill you the way that you thought it
would is it
something worth thinking about you know
it may be too there's another thing
worth thinking about
it may be that the more that you focus
just on this level
the more time you spend just at this
level not paying attention to this it'll
be harder
to do this that's one reason why
having you know a lot of dating a lot of
people may not actually be the best idea
in all cases
you know some people think of it as like
but it's sort of like having a lot of
lottery tickets the more tickets you
have the better chance you have in
winning right
but to develop intimacy with somebody
you actually have to spend a lot of time
with them you have to get to know them
you have to get to know what they value
you probably have to get to know their
other friends and their family
and what makes them tick you have to
have that sort of
interest in who they are and drive to
know
who they are and there's one other thing
presupposed by this too
they actually have to be lovable i mean
you may not be able to have that kind of
relationship
with somebody who's a thoroughly bad
person if in fact you know let's say you
get involved in a romantic relationship
and you find out that the person that
you're involved with is actually
a con artist you're probably not going
to be able to have this this is probably
going to be the best you can get
from them so you you actually have to
find other people who are like you
in wanting to develop that level
what if you have uneven friendships
aristotle talks about cases where you
have what he calls mixed
or uneven friendships and this is really
important
in part because a lot of your
relationships are probably of this sort
so let's just consider friends to begin
with let's not look at like family or
you know any of those sort of roles
let's just think about people that
you're friends with
can there be cases uh we have you know
a couple different combination
possibilities could be that one person
is friends with the other person because
they're getting usefulness
from the other person and
the other friend is getting pleasure
from the
friend are there relationships like that
where one person is getting some sort of
external good
and the other person is getting pleasure
sure um if you keep somebody around and
you buy their drinks because they're
funny
um and they're willing to hang around
and you know
invite them to dinner because they're
funny or something like that but they
don't really like you that much
and the only thing you really like about
them is that they're funny
that's it you know they're getting
usefulness they're getting a free meal
or drinks or
business contacts or whatever you want
from it
and you're getting pleasure what could
what could be some other examples of
that where
somebody's what are things you could pay
somebody for
to provide you with pleasure
you know your friend is only in a very
derivative sense
some people hang around with other
people just because you know they invite
him to parties
it's how kids get to be popular you know
some of the popular set
are only popular because they're able to
provide usefulness to other people
and those other people have better be
pleasant or else they're not going to
get invited
are they or they're not going to get
invited invited back
you can think of a lot of other examples
if we want something really
sort of uh crude and raw prostitution
yeah is that what you're going to say no
i should say i had a relationship with
class here that a girl
wanted to get on the team that i'm on
everyone told me that they thought she
was only becoming friends with me
in order to get a teacher yeah and as
soon as she got on the team
she started like she was still friends
with me
and now she's like since she's on a team
she's
yeah that's probably you know that's how
you can tell
yeah when that's the case um there's
lots of things that we
want from other people but they tend to
be the same basic things money
opportunities entrance to some sort of
club access to somebody else's friends
or business contacts or
maybe their school
trading favors off with each other um
what else getting invited to to things
food drink security
you know i think think of romantic well
let's take the prostitution example
again
somebody is paying somebody else for sex
they're doing it for pleasure right i
mean if you're paying for sex
hopefully you're actually getting some
pleasure out of it otherwise the money
is kind of wasted
i think i'm not sure how much
pleasure you can actually buy because
you know
that's the side of the world that i stay
away from but
there's definitely some sort of
relationship there
and you can imagine one taking place
over time
you know somebody's a regular client
there's no illusions that the other
person really loves who they are
i hope people do sometimes fall into
that sort of thing
really one person is getting money out
of it usefulness the other person is
getting
pleasure you can think of romantic
relationships where somebody's trying to
get something out of
another person and the one person likes
having that person around they're easy
on the eyes they
they're fun to talk to they're a good
dancer or whatever
but the other person is mainly
interested in financial security
or in getting
access to some sort of resource
or getting hired staying hired
i suppose if a boss were to coerce an
employee
into a romantic relationship
or sometimes people do this the other
way right the employee
seduces the boss that happens
that goes on until both people aren't
getting what they want out of it
i knew a guy actually this just came to
mind
i worked at a shaky's pizza restaurant
when i was um
about your age i was an undergraduate
and
one of the managers had his girlfriend
was going to
carroll college one of the local
colleges
and everybody i didn't know the guy that
well everybody who knew him was saying
to him
she's just using him as soon as
she graduates she's going to be gone
because we can tell she doesn't really
like you
you know now she was pretty
and you know she was pleasant for him to
be with
um but sure enough as soon as she
graduated like within a week of
graduation and they were engaged in a
week of graduation
she broke up with him because she no
longer needed him
she no longer had need for the money
that he was supplying he paid for the
whole thing
you know and he was an assistant manager
in a restaurant so he was working you
know
60 hours a week
in a not particularly fun job
dealing with a bunch of kids you know
um after that he went off the deep end
because now like his whole world was
shattered
i think he thought that he was at this
level where he knew her
you know and he started drinking heavily
and he actually got in trouble for uh
for stealing after embezzling i don't
think he would have done that
beforehand you can just see his decline
these these sort of things are important
moral issues
what about usefulness and um
virtue you know
there are some cases where we like
people who are virtuous people who have
good characters we want them around
we want to be involved with them there's
something attractive
about those who are actually genuinely
good
who genuinely has something to offer
this is why people go to famous teachers
and they want to
interact with them and they pay lots of
money to go to these seminars
because there are some people out there
who are genuinely virtuous
some of them are frauds granted but some
of them aren't some of them are the real
deal
it could be that somebody else doesn't
have that to offer them
you know let's say they want to learn
how to be a good person but they're not
a good person yet
they can't offer this to the other
person in return
but they can't offer money or they can
offer
hey come come stay at my place be our
guru in residence you know they can't
offer that sort of thing
the same thing could go for pleasure too
if you find yourself
involved with somebody who's who you
genuinely acknowledge to be
really well put together they are
somebody you would like to be
like somebody who you admire somebody
who you emulate
but you're not there yet
and they're happy to have you around
because they like the way that you
interact with them you give them some
sort of pleasure that's okay
again that's a mixed relationship that's
not on the same level as
two people who genuinely are good people
interacting with each other as good
people in terms of their character
fully knowing each other but it is still
a good thing
they're actually doing you a favor and
later on down the line
should you become that virtuous person
he would be very generous of you
to be involved in relationships where
other people can only offer you utility
usefulness while you know inviting you
to dinner parties things like that
or they can only offer you pleasure you
would actually be doing them a good turn
wouldn't you because what this person is
supplying is much better
than what this person is supplying or
this person
um so you know what about other
kinds of um mixed relationships those
are ones that just have to do with sort
of people coming to each other
from the outside what are some of the
relationships that you found yourself
in and you didn't have a choice about it
what's the first one you started out a
relationship that what you said
you didn't have a choice about it you're
stuck with it yeah you're parents
um and aristotle talks about this um
the relationship between child and
parent is probably
a mixed relationship unless you
actually get to this point and that's
not going to happen while you're still a
child
that'll happen when you're actually an
adult provided your parents are actually
really good people
i mean in order to have this this level
of relationship you actually have to be
at that
at that point it could be that um
you know you provide each other
enjoyment at the very least
you're useful to each other right
some people will break off relations
with their parents especially
you know if if all that the parents had
to offer was financial backing
then what incentive do you have to be
connected with them to continue their
relationship maybe a sense of duty
yeah i mean you're more obligated than
anything yeah aristotle talks about that
too doesn't he says
they gave you being that's kind of a big
thing
um but a lot of people in our society
don't recognize that and i think a lot
of people even in his society
didn't recognize that there are people
who become estranged from their
their families their parents
their own children sometimes
because there's something lacking there
i mean
if you actually have this if you
actually have virtue good character
that'll get you through an awful lot
that pleasure or just
usefulness won't because these are more
shifting um
there are some things that parents
generally take pleasure in their
children
so that's a good thing otherwise they
might abandon them
you know parents generally
feel affectionate he thinks towards
their children he
also talks about some other interesting
examples too he says
sometimes there's a superiority of one
one party over the other there's a
father and son
older person and a younger
ruler and the person's ruled he also you
know i do have to point this out
aristotle's writing at a time it's very
male dominated so husband and wife he
places the husband on a higher level
than the wife but there's no there's no
reason why
if he were here today he would
necessarily stick to that and he could
say there's
probably many cases where one of the
person
in the marriage is at this level and
then the other person
is only able to provide one of these
you know think of how many people do the
job of holding a marriage together
you know that's a lot of work now the
other person is not doing an
awful lot of that work because they're
not able to do that
um they're only able to provide say
maybe well maybe they're able they're a
good
income earner and that's about it the
other person is really doing the job of
holding that marriage or even
the household together or they're you
know able to give pleasure
but they're not able to keep things
going um
and he says that you know these unequal
friendships the benefit
that one party receives and is entitled
to claim from the other is not the same
the friendship between parents and
children will be enduring and equitable
when the children render to the parents
of services due to the authors due to
one's being
he's not saying that the children have
to do exactly back to the parents what
the parents did for them
that's probably not even possible is it
but we've talked about this in this
class you a lot of you feel like you
have obligations to your parents
because they've done so much for you and
how would you actually see those
obligations through
one way is by what you're doing here
making it through school
making the success out of yourself right
somebody who had expressed that before
giving back to other people later on
down the line
being a good parent yourself when you
get the chance down the line
those would be ways in which you would
give back
he says that the the affection in this
sort of relationships ought to be
proportionate
so if there is an imbalance the one
who's lower really ought to have
more affection for the one who's giving
the higher thing
it does it doesn't always work that way
does it but
oftentimes in families it does
when things are going well
the very last thing that i want to talk
about with this
is um
he considers the question who can have
what kind of relationships
good people can have relationships at
any one of these levels
um what about bad people people who have
bad care nutrients who aren't saying
manipulated
looked at this before be the other two
what's that maybe and they may not
actually even recognize
this sometimes you hear people making
excuses saying oh we all just use each
other
what does that reveal to you that
reveals to you that they think
relationships are
only at this level you know
that they can't even see a higher thing
that means they're not going to be
capable of a higher thing so long as
they're
they're in that framework that point of
view
um
bad people can't have a friendship of
the higher type in part because bad
people can only be
friends when they're getting something
out of it themselves
this is more lasting
good people are able to have this
because you actually start to like the
person for who they are
not for what you get from them
you recognize them for who they are
that's why you can't you can't
have this sort of friendship aristotle
things with a bad person because
if you actually know who they are you're
not going to like it right
um it's interesting too he talks about
can you be friends with yourself
it says yes you can and the good person
is friends with himself the bad person
really doesn't like themselves
the more that they do get to know who
they are
at this level the more they're going to
recoil from
so the bad person is always you might
say stuck in
a state of misrecognition
of who they are the last thing to say
about this is this kind of friendship
here it says
is proof against what he calls
calumny which really means saying bad
things about each other
or suspicion at these levels
you're always a little bit worried that
you know
maybe they're only friends with me for
what they're getting from you maybe they
really don't like me
maybe if they really did get to know me
they wouldn't like me
at this level you actually can be secure
so that's where we'll leave